- If you're the face of the
business, put out content.
I put out content,
VaynerMedia puts out content,
we both put out content.
Content, content, content, content.
The answer to every
question is more content.
More content.
(hip-hop beat)
Sunday morning, NBA
All-Star, Staples Center.
Just been network and business stuff here
with our Mountain Dew client.
Kickstart, gonna go in, see what's up
then head to San Francisco.
He's such a good dude.
- There's a guy who used to work at Vayner
who's doing all the production
stuff with all your brand.
- Sup man?
Just the man we been looking for.
- How you doing brother?
- Good my guy.
- You going up?
- No no, I'm chillin',
I'm just with my client.
- Oh okay.
- How are you?
- I'm good man, I'm good.
- Stuff is good?
- Yeah.
This is my sister right here.
Kristina.
This is Gary Vee.
- Hey Kristina, how are you?
Nice to meet you.
You good?
Good, good.
- What you up to, what are you guys doing?
- I just came in, chopped
it up with some people,
bouncing now and go to San
Francisco in a couple hours.
- Oh dope, dope, dope.
What are you doing in San Fran?
- Starting to trying to
win a Super Bowl baby.
Buy the Jets, win a Super Bowl.
- Yeah I love it, I love it.
- You hit me any time
like I said, any time.
- Thank you brother.
- Anything.
'Cause it's crazy.
- I agree.
- Because I think you
should be more activations
for the content capturing.
- I don't care about
what's happening in here.
- It's what people are
seeing about it digitally.
- Is there a new flavor here
for me to try at Kickstart?
- There's two flavors.
- Here we go.
As you guys know, the old wine world,
I know how to analyze beverages.
Very Mountain Dewy in its flavor.
This Kickstart Mountain Dew,
original Dew flavor so
the dewiness makes sense.
I can do some Dew.
Feel like I'm in a fuckin' commercial.
When you make it, pick the 39
that you're most excited about
and literally go like, you know set it up
for like a minute or
first 10 seconds of like
we fuckin' crushed it, it was amazing
and then one, two, three,
four, you know like
even as you're showing
them, number three like
so that they can really
understand like yet exactly.
Like I want them to
understand the level of assets
and then maybe even like a box of like
recommended segmentation.
- Yeah exactly.
- Hey Gary.
- See you later.
- Oh you're headed out?
- Headed out, gotta go.
Sup my guy, how are you?
- You Gary?
- I am.
- Oh, hi.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you man.
- I love your stuff.
I saw your shoes, I was like.
- That's how you do.
(laughing)
- Can you sign my shirt man?
- Yeah man.
- Thank you man.
- Thanks man.
- My guy Mike Boyd introduced us.
I'm Job, I'm the guy that does the A3C
hip-hop festival in Atlanta man.
Can I get a photo with you?
- 100%
- Me and this dude gotta
do business eventually.
- Just a matter of time my guy.
- See you guys, take care.
- Thank you so much, take care, thank you.
Heading to Napa for some shh.
Hope everybody's doing super well.
Sunday afternoon vibes.
It is 2:50 P.M. here on the west coast.
Headed to the airport and here with Babin.
Babin life, it's the best life.
Is Drock gonna meet us at the airport?
At the airport here.
- [Babin] Yeah, he's on the way.
- He's on the way too.
- [Babin] Yeah.
- So it's me, you,
Drock, Nate, whole crew,
oh both of you are filming.
- [Babin] Yeah.
- 'Cause it's really--
Oh by the way, First In Line.
Everybody who's on right now, message me
right now on Facebook, right
now, message me on Facebook.
If you haven't, join First In Line
by text message and
Facebook messenger service
for jabs and right hooks.
Things like I'll send to First
In Line in a couple hours
with the information of
7:00 to 8:00 A.M. in LA
to get my sneaker to be in the lottery.
Things of that nature.
I give away 50 books.
So just say hi, just write First In Line
right now on messenger.
You'll get an auto respond back and,
and then you can fill
out the information and
you will be in the mix.
So join First In Line.
If you're not in First In
Line, join First In Line,
the Gary Vee First In Line system.
Giving away free shwag, talked
to a bunch of hot brands.
Doing a lot of contests,
it's the way to get
lunch and breakfasts with me.
One hour of Drock's time I gave away,
yes I'm about to give away.
Babin you in too?
- [Babin] Yeah.
- One free hour consultation
worth $5000 to $10000
of Bobby, Babin and Drock on how to vlog
and how to create content at scale.
First In Line's gonna be
the greatest shit ever.
The Facebook Messenger and
text messaging platform
that I've just created,
the Gary Vee First In Line.
Very easy to join when
you're here on Facebook Live
because all you've gotta
do is just hit Messenger.
Just message me right now and just reply
what's up, what's up, what's up.
First In Line, Hello First
In Line, Hello First In Line,
First In Line question mark, what's up,
get me on First In Line, I
wanna be on First In Line,
First In Line, First
In Line, First In Line,
FL, FL, FL exclamation point, FL, FL.
FL Life, FL space Life,
however you wanna reply
and start the conversation with me,
you will get an automated response
with the form to fill out.
I'm First In Line, First
In Line, First In Line.
Did you get that?
- [Babin] It's gonna flash
up every time you say it.
- I felt like I was the Gucci
Mane, Gucci Mane, Gucci Mane.
First In Line, First
In Line, First In Line.
First In Line.
First In Line, First In Line,
First In Line, First In Line.
What up Zack, what up Zack, what up Zack?
Style girl, no regret, can't regret.
Not yet.
Too young to regret.
Too young to have regrets right now.
Regrets are, regrets are
for the fourth quarter
when shit's almost finished.
Way too young, all of you are
way too young for regrets.
Right now, right now if you're regretting,
if you're regretting and you're under 80,
you're actually dwelling not regretting.
You're dwelling not regretting.
It seizes your moment.
Johnny I did, the book's coming.
If you're the face of the
business, put out content.
I put out content,
VaynerMedia puts out content,
we both put out content.
Content, content, content, content.
The answer to every
question is more content.
More content.
There's too much bad content.
There's never too much good content.
Like content and you don't
know if you have good content
and you gotta let the market decide.
So the answer for right
while there's a land grab
is just more fuckin' content.
More content, more content because
99% of people are just not
putting out enough content.
So I'm not worried about the 1% that are.
So the answer is fuckin' more content.
(hip-hop music)